même si le geste est un peu hésitant les
élèves du lycée dumont-d'urville de mort
pas rompu totaux long de la matinée se
mettre dans la peau de personnes en
situation de handicap pour pratiquer le
vélo qui sont très investis
il alterne bien les différents ateliers
ça leur permet aussi de découvrir bas
différentes disciplines
concernant le handisport cette
manifestation a été mise en place par
les élèves de la mention complémentaire
animation et gestion de projets dans le
secteur sportif
le handisport un thème qui a fait
l'unanimité au sein de la classe ce
qu'on trouve que c'est pas assez
développée en france ou même à
l'étranger que que les personnes en
difficulté ont vraiment besoin dead ou
même de deux subventions
c'est vraiment important en fait parmi
les intervenants le vc e sky
le vélo club basé à elancourt a ouvert
en 2013 une section handisport et compte
douze licenciés moi c'est important de
montrer qu'on peut être handicapé et
continuer à faire du sport et quand sa
part montrée du doigt et faire voir que
on peut faire dire ce qu'on veut en
fauteuil on leur explique qu'on continue
à faire des sports la musculation
au quotidien nous entretenir et le vélo
c'est d'évasion au programme également
de cette journée de sensibilisation des
rencontres l'après midi avec des
athlètes paralympiques